gleich zu Beginn aber sind wir verbunden
in Tel Aviv mit Melodie sucharewitch die
wir in Deutschland als politische
Beraterin kennen und die jetzt glaube
ich in einer Wohnung in Tel Aviv mit
ihren beiden Kindern aushart guten Abend
nach
Israel guten Abend Frau sucharwitch ich
Satz von ihnen der sich mir eingebrannt
hat es ist die lebende Hölle zur Zeit
wie ist denn die Sicherheitslage im
Moment in Tel
Aviv
es ist die lebende Hölle und sie ist
leider noch nicht vorbei und währendd
wir noch 800 tote haben massakrierte
Menschen die noch nicht mal begraben
werden konnten geht der Terror weiter
wir sind ständig unter Raketenbeschuss
der Süden nonstop Tel Aviv heute immer
wieder es versuchen Terroristen der
Hamas weiterhin einzudringen in
israelisches Gebiet sowohl im Süden als
auch vom Norden die hisbolla hat es
heute versucht die hat es gestern
versucht es gibt Raketen bereits aus dem
Norden
ähm es ist ein Inferno es ist ein
bestialischer Krieg von einer Dimension
die ihn Israel nicht kannte die ih
glaube ich wenige westliche Länder
demokratische westlicher Länder Länder
können und wir stecken noch mittend drin
und bereiten uns darauf vor dass das
noch viele Wochen vielleicht Monate
dauern wird die Zahl der Toten erhöht
sich fast stündlich hab jetzt auch schon
Zahlen von über 1000 gelesen wir lesen
unfassbare Dinge von enthaupteten Babys
enthauptete Menschen
Frauen Kinder alte alle massakriert in
Wohnungen zum Teil aufgefunden es
berichten die Kollegen von Bild vor
wenigen Stunden sie sagen wir sind hier
Krieg gewohnt wir sind Terror gewohnt
aber das hier hat eine Dimension eine
Bestialität die kennen auch wir so nicht
das heißt wie muss man sich das
vorstellen ich würde sie auch gerne als
Mutter fragen sie sind Mutter von zwei
Kindern wie erklären Sie den was da vor
sich
geht wir sind Krieg und Terror in Israel
gewohnt und ich habe in der Tat
miterlebt den Unterschied einer
intifadaer als junge Studentin als ich
aus als München Abiturientin nach Israel
gezogen bin und ein terroratentaten nach
dem anderen erlebt hab und wie sich das
so entwickelt über die Jahre und wie
sich das alles verändert wenn man dann
Kinder hat und wenn man diese Kinder aus
dem Schlaf reißen muss und in den Bunker
schleppen um sie vor Raketen zu schützen
wie erklärt man es ihnen man schützt sie
soweit es geht vor der Realität
mit Raketen haben sie es gelernt zu
leben sie kennen die Geschichte dass wir
diesen netten iron Dome haben es gibt
Zeichentrickfilme mit mit denen wir
Ihnen erklären dass der Iron Dome eine
Netze eine gute Rakete ist die sie
schützt für den vor den bösen Raketen
und deshalb sind sie sicher und im
Bunker sind Sie sicher und versuchen
diese hässliche unerträgliche
unverdauliche Realität vor ihnen zu
verheimlichen dass Kinder ihren Alters
jetzt gerade wenn sie noch am Leben sind
in den bestialischen Händen der Hamas
sind im gaserstreifen gefoltert werden
weggerissen von ihren Müttern
weggerissen von ihren Familien viele der
Eltern wurden vor ihren Augen zermetzelt
bevor man die Kinder verschleppt hat vor
dieser Realität versuchen wir unsere
eigenen Kinder zu schützen währenddem
wir um die anderen Kinder die weniger
Glück hatten im Süden Weinen mhm und
darf ich fragen ist es zutreffend dass
ihr Mann der Vater ihrer Kinder zu den
Reservisten gehört die jetzt auch
eingezogen worden sind die mobil gemacht
wurden die jetzt im im Einsatz sind die
jetzt plötzlich sich als Soldaten in
diesem Krieg wie
wiederfinden ja mein Mann ist einer der
300.000 Reservisten die eingezogen
wurden das stimmt
mhm wissen ihre Kinder wo ihr Vater ist
wie erklären sie das ich ich frage
deswegen weil ich eben eine Idee davon
habe was das bedeutet und was Leben
unter solchen Umständen bedeutet
deswegen frage ich sie auch diese
intimen Dinge aber ich glaube wir
sollten den Leuten sehr genau mal
erklären was das wirklich bedeutet und
was das für ein Zivilisationsbruch war
der da stattgefunden hat und offenbar
immer noch
stattfindet ich kann Ihnen sagen ähm
dass äh Kinder in Israel es gewohnt sind
ihre Väter auch wenn sie keine 20 Jahre
alt mehr sind äh in Uniform zu
sehen ich kann Ihnen sagen dass ich
meinen Mann bei allen letzten
Operationen wie schlimm sie auch waren
noch nie so gesehen hab
wie dieses Mal und ich kann nur hoffen
dass meine Kinder das nicht mitbekommen
haben ich meine bevor er bevor er
abgezogen ist aber genauso wie alle
anderen Reservisten und genauso wie
unsere aktiven
Soldaten gibt es nur eine Sache die
jetzt zählt und das ist nicht trauern
das ist nicht Angst haben sondern es ist
stark sein nach vorne gucken geeint sein
und hinter unserer Armee zueh
und sich darauf zu verlassen dass Sie
das Richtige tun um uns die
Zivilgesellschaft die die Homefront die
die Bevölkerung zu schützen die eigenen
Kinder zu schützen aber auch Israel
strategische Interessen zu schützen und
dafür zu sorgen dass diese bestialische
islamistische Hamas die sich wirklich
nicht von
Isis unterscheidet das sehen Sie selber
in den Bildern die jetzt durch die
sozialen Medien gehen dass sie so ein
niemals wieder anrichten kann und dass
Israel und die Menschen in Israel Süden
und die Menschen in ganz Israel die
Kinder sicher in ihren Betten schlafen
können ohne Angst haben zu müssen dass
sie von diesen Bestien nachts
herausgrisschen
werden sie sagten gerade diese Bilder
das ist auch ein Krieg der Bilder den
wir da sehen und die Hamas setzt diese
Bilder auf sehr perfide Art und Weise
ein ähm
was würden Sie sagen Frau sucharewit
auch eine resiliente Gesellschaft wie
die
israelische wie viele dieser Bilder ist
eine Gesellschaft ist ein Land imstande
auszuhalten die Diskussionen darüber der
unendliche Schmerz darüber über das was
passiert ist über verschleppte Kinder
über alte Menschen die verschleppt
worden sind die grultaten die nach und
nach an die Öffentlichkeit kommen wie
viel ist eine Gesellschaft in der Lage
zu
ertragen
sie kennen die Geschichte des jüdischen
Volkes und sie wissen dass wir es leider
leider gelernt haben das unerträglichste
und das
unfassbarste zu ertragen zu
überwinden und stark zu bleiben und zu
überleben und das ist dieses kollektive
Gedächtnis und diese kollektive
Identität die es uns jetzt ermöglicht
über diesen
Horror diesen Terror diese
Bestialität nicht hinwegzukommen weil
man kann nicht darüber hinwegkommen aber
weiter machen wir überleben und wir
werden die Hamas und alle Feinde die es
daruf absehen jetzt in mit Israel einen
Krieg eine kriegsfont zu eröffnen wir
werden sie besiegen und es wird so ein
Massaker auf israelischenem Boden nicht
mehr geben den genau dafür gibt es den
jüdischen Staat um die Menschen zu
schützen Carlo Masala ist bei uns
Militärexperte ich habe es eben schon
erwähnt Herr marala sie sagen das ist
das israelische 9eleven das ist das
israelische Pearl Harbor denn dieser
Angriff ist erfolgt bis tief ins Land
hinein was bedeutet das für die nächsten
Tage für die nächsten Wochen was kommt
auf den Nahen Osten
zu also es ist ja bereits gesagt worden
das erklärte Ziel der israelischen
Regierung ist es die Hamas als
militärischen und politischen Akteur in
Gaza zu
vernichten es wird zu einer umfassenden
bodenoperation kommen die wie bereits
eben auch gesagt worden ist sicherlich
die wird nicht in vier oder F Tagen
vorbei sein die wird Wochen dauern wenn
nicht gar Monate aber die wird schnell
beginnen die wird in den nächsten Tagen
beginnen also ich meine es ist sozusagen
alles vorbereitet die israelische
Regierung hat am Anfang gesagt im
Prinzip geht's um drei Stufen es geht um
die Wiedererlangung der Souveränität und
Kontrolle auf israelischen Territorium
jetzt sickern zwar immer wieder noch
Hamas Terroristen nach Israel ein aber
letztenendes kann man sagen die
Kontrolle über das israelische
Territorium ist jetzt fast
wiederhergestellt worden damit fängt die
Stufe 2 an also wir haben ja gesehen
dass es sozusagen eine eine luftkampagne
gab gegen militärische Ziele der Hamas
im im Gaza die dient natürlich auch der
Vorbereitung der Bodenoffensive das ist
relativ klassisch und wir werden als
nächstes eine umfassende Bodenoffensive
sehen das Häuserkampf das ist
Häuserkampf also das ist sozusagen was
man nennt Uran Warfare da wird in einer
Stadt gekämpft und das war sozusagen die
Vorbereitung der der Hauptquartiere von
Hamas und man mit sogenannten
präzisionsschlägen dann soll man sich
auch kein Illusion hingeben das wird
blutig das wird mit einer hohen Anzahl
von Opfern einhergehen auch auf
israelischer Seite weil Warfare ist eine
der komplexesten Operationen und
gleichzeitig auch für die Streitkräfte
die Sie durchführen eine der
gefährlichsten Operationen die man
durchführen kann und wie gesagt es wird
Wochen oder Monate dauern gleichzeitig
muss Israel dafür sorgen dass es keine
zweite Front eröffnet wird im Norden
Israel durch die hzbollah das ist ja das
was wir in den vergangenen Tagen gesehen
haben also ich würde noch nicht davon
sprechen dass es eine zweite Front ist
aber es gibt Raketenbeschuss einzelne
Hisbollah Terroristen dringen nach
Israel ein die Frage wird sein wird die
hzbollah die militärisch weitaus stärker
ist als die Hamas das muss man auch mal
klar festhalten Libanon beherrscht die
den Libanon kontrolliert politisch und
militärisch wird die sozusagen
vollumfänglich versuchen in diesen
Konflikt mit einzustigen und dann
befindet sich Israel an einem
Zweifrontenkrieg das muss man so
deutlich sagen und dann darüber hinaus
gibt's natürlich unzählige weitere
Szenarien die man im Auge behalten muss
damit das nicht zu einem komplett
unkontrollierbaren Flächenbrand im sich
im mittleren und Nahen Osten entwickelt
die Amerikaner versuchen Hezbollah und
den Iran davon abzuhalten in diesen
Konflikt einzutreten also das ist ist
das was beiden gesagt hat ne kein
externer Akteur soll sich da einmischen
das ist auch das was Olaf Scholz gesagt
hat in seiner Ansprache ich glaube
gestern war die und die Amerikaner
schicken halt ihre Carrier group also
die USS for die im Mittelmeerraum ist
näher ran an Israel und das ist ein
Zeichen an die hesbollah und den Iran
mischt euch nicht ein ob diese
Abschreckung funktionieren wird mit
Blick auf die hesbollah müssen wir sehen
ansonsten besteht das Risiko dass Israel
sich in einem Zweifrontenkrieg befindet
und darüber hinaus noch weitere
Implikationen die man jetzt noch nicht
absehen kann und von denen wir alle
sozusagen hoffen dass sie nicht
eintreten ich k weil gerade der Name des
Kanzlers gefallen ist Olaf Scholz
Israels Schutz staatsreson das ist
sozusagen noch mal mehr als zu sagen wir
geben dort Sicherheitsgarantie wir
stehen an eurer Seite das das ist das
ist eine sehr weitreichende
Ansage die Frage ist und die Debatten
wird dann natürlich auch sehr schnell
geben Herr marala nickt schon wie wollen
wir das mit Leben füllen das ist doch
das worauf ankommt richtig das ist
bestimmt
ähm schnell gesagt und das ist bestimmt
auch ähm richtig dass der Kanzler diese
Garantie gegeben hat also staatsreson
die Sicherheit Israels ist deutsche
staatsreson merkel hatte es schon 2008
vor der Knesset gesagt aber was bedeutet
es es bedeutet dass Deutschland
militärisch finanziell
humanitär Hilfe leisten muss solange
Israel diese benötigt und auch in einem
Umfang in dem Israel sie fordert und
wenn man dann mal darauf schaut dass wir
in die Ukraine Waffen liefern dass die
Bundeswehr schon Schwierigkeiten hat in
litaauen ihre Versprechen für die NATO
zu erfüllen und jetzt noch dies das wird
ein weitere zusätzliche Belastung sein
für Deutschland und das muss der Kanzler
nebendem dass er sagt das ist
staatsrison und da wird er
wahrscheinlich auch ein großen Teil der
Bevölkerung hinter sich haben es ist gut
dass es heute alle Parteien der
demokratischen Mitte im Bundestag
geschafft haben eine gemeinsame
Resolution die den gleichen Tonus hat
rauszugeben aber dass je länger dieser
Krieg dauert und wenn Israel ein
Zweifrontenkrieg hat und wir haben nahe
an Europa dann zwei Kriege dran dann
wird das sehr schwer sein die
Bevölkerung tatsächlich bei der Stange
zu halten genau und bevor wir gleich
sozusagen die demokratische Mitte Fragen
will ich einal noch cararlo masaler
Fragen das bedeutet und vielleicht kann
das auch Frau sucharewit beantworten das
bedeutet doch übersetzt dass Deutschland
dann auch militärische Hilfe leisten
müsste sollte also dieser Begriff äh
Israels Sicherheit ist Teil der
deutschen staatsresor ähm Frau
kottbecker hat richtig gesagt Angela
Merkel hat das zweimal gebraucht diesen
Begriff 2008 und dann bei ihrer
Abschiedsrede 2021 beides mal vor der
Knesset die Parteivorsitzenden der
demokratischen Parteien haben ja einen
gemeinsamen Brief oder ein Aufruf
verfasst wo das auch noch mal zentral
ist man muss aber sagen es ist ja nie in
Deutschland auch ausbuchstabiert worden
was das bedeutet deswegen aber jetzt
wird's gerade konkret jetzt wird's
gerade konkret und wenn man das wirklich
ernst meint also wenn man wirklich ernst
meint ist Teil der deutschen staatsreson
dann hat das ja moralisch politisch so
eine Art Verfassungsrang und dann
bedeutet das in dem Moment indem die
Existenz Israels auf dem Spiel steht
müsste Deutschland gegebenenfalls bereit
sein aktiv Israel zu verteidigen das ist
die logische Konsequenz dies
aktiv verteigen staatssison bedeutet ja
sozusagen etwas was der Gesellschaft
übergeordnet ist und dem Erhalt des
Staates dient und wenn Israels
Sicherheit ein Teil der deutschen
Staatsraison ist dann ist sozusagen wenn
Israels Existenz gefährdet ist leitet
sich daraus ab dass man eigentlich aktiv
zur Verteidigung Israels beitragen
müsste und zwar vollumfänglich
vollumfänglich heißt dann nicht nur un
Anführungszeichen Waffen liefern
sonder wenn die Existenz ja also wir
sind noch nicht in dieser Situation ja
aber ich also
W sie wissen oder können das nicht jetzt
mitkriegen gerade jetzt h ich gerade aus
den aus der Regie Kollegen sagen gerade
Angriffe aus
Syrien Israel Antwort der israelischen
Armee offenbar auch schon da das heißt
da wird auf jeden Fall gezündelt und das
ist ja die große Gefahr und ist auch die
Sorge die uns heute Abend hier treibt
und deswegen sollte sich die deutsche
Politik jetzt mal sozusagen das muss
nicht öffentlich sein aber sozusagen
hinter verschlossenen Türen
in die Diskussion begeben was dieser
Begriff eigentlich letztten Endes
bedeutet mhm weil die situ die Situation
so wie sie ist hat das Potenzial ich sag
nicht dass es so kommen wird aber hat
das Potenzial dass die Existenz Israels
auf dem Spiel steht das muss man ganz
einfach so sagen vielleicht fragen wir
Frau sucharewiic die zuhört in Tel Aviv
und die ich gerne fragen würde ist das
das Gefühl und der zweite Teil der Frage
was erwartet Israel was erwartet
israelische Gesellschaft an dem Punkt
von Deutschland speziell von
Deutschland
in allererster Linie Solidarität und die
Solidarität die wir seit Ausbruch dieses
Krieges sehen ist bewegend und sie ist
wichtig aber und da gibt es zwei
Abers die erste Frage ist wie lange wird
sie anhalten mhm
Israel wird die Hamas
ztrümmern müssen um seine eigene
Sicherheit
nachhaltig zu
sichern und die Hamas und das ist das
ist nichts Neues benutzt die eigene
Bevölkerung als Schutzschilder es wird
Tote geben wahrscheinlich auch
Zivilisten was keiner möchte auf
palästinensischer Seite was sich aber
aufgrund der bestialischen
Vorgehensweise der Hamas nicht vermeiden
lässt die Frage ist bleibt auch dann die
Solidarität standhaft die zweite Frage
ist ist es jetzt eine eher staatlich
politisch vorgegebene
Solidarität oder oder trifft sie
wirklich auch das Herz der deutschen
Straße und hier glaube ich kommen wir zu
einem Aspekt der in den letzten Jahren
vielleicht Jahrzehnten vernachlässigt
wurde in Deutschland und ich glaube das
war ein fataler Fehler wir haben ja
jrelang gesehen wie es alkutzmärche in
Berlin gab und dieselben
palästinensischen Extremisten die das
Massaker an den Juden vor zwei Tagen in
Neuköln auf der Straße gefeiert haben
haben feiern frei Haus auf Deutschlands
Straßen schon seit vielen vielen Jahren
mit antisemitischen grälichen Parolen
mit antiwestlichen antidemokratischen
grälichen Parolen und sie tun es mit dem
verständnisvollen vielleicht peinlichen
Blick sowohl der Politik als auch der
Gesellschaft das heißt man guckt Weg es
ist eben nicht so klar wie Russland und
Ukraine wo jede Schule überhaupt ohne
zweimal drüber nachzudenken eine Flagge
aufhängt sondern es ist halt Palästina
und Israel aus dieser
straßenperspektive oft aus dieser
stammtischperspektive und das ist
irgendwie so im Bewusstsein viele
Menschen eine grauzzone wo man sich
diesen Antisemitismus vielleicht schön
reden schön denken oder einfach
weggucken kann und das war ein Fehler
und das darf es nicht mehr geben nach
dem 7
Oktober kann es keine islamistischen
Extremisten mehr auf deutschen Straßen
geben mit antisemitischen
antizionistischen Parolen ohne dass
irgendetwas dagegen getan wird sie
dürfen es es da diese Bilder kann man
nicht mehr sehen und ich glaube das ist
etwas was Israel wirklich
erwartet dass diese
Grauzone einer schwarzen Zone wird und
dass Deutschland durchgreift und zwar
nicht nur für einen Tag und zwei Tage
sondern nachhaltig dass diese
Solidarität die nicht nur aus
moralischen Gründen Imperativ ist gerade
sondern die auch ein eigenes
strategisches Interesse Deutschland ist
dass diese Solidarität bestehen bleibt
und dass sie vor allem von Worten in
Taten umgewandelt wird und da kommen wir
zu einem ganz wichtigen Punkt nämlich
woher komm diese Waffen woher kommt die
Aufrüstung der Hamas und es ist
einerseits klar und es ist kein
Geheimnis mehr dass der Iran dahinter
steht und dass der Iran seit vielen
Jahren die Hamas palästinen Islamic
Jihad genauso wie die Hisbollah
aufrüstet trainiert finanziert die
Hisbollah alleine mit 700 Millionen
Dollar im Jahr und dass der Iran und das
ist auch keine gute Nachricht für
Deutschland in Kooperation mit
hamasführern die die in Istanbul leben
die dort ihr finanzielles und operatives
Zentrum haben in Istanbul im Wissen und
teilskooperation der Türkei dass der
Iran gemeinsam dieses Massaker geplant
hat das ist der eine Aspekt der Iran ist
das iranische
Regime ist der Sponsor des
palästinensischen Terrors den wir gerade
hier erleben und hinzuomt dass die Hamas
ob gewollt oder ungewollt seit vielen
Jahren von den hunderten Millionen
europäischer Steuerzahler oder
Steuergelder profitieren die in die
palästinensische Infrastruktur fließen
genau und das ist ein Punkt über den wir
mit Sicherheit sprechen sollten und wo
Deutschland und das ist eine Sache die
in Israel erwartet wird die Politik zu
einer zero tolerance Politik ändern muss
uch rewit sie haben jetzt viele Themen
angesprochen die wir tatsächlich einzeln
abarbeiten müssen das ist wichtig das zu
tun auch über Istanbul müssen wir reden
über die Rolle der Türkei müssen wir
reden über Leute die zum Teil mit
türkischen Pässen natoitglied
wohlgemerkt ausgestattet werden und dann
sehr leicht auch
in die Europäische Union einreisen und
so weiter und so weiter deswegen sagte
ich vorhin das ist auch unser Krieg und
es gibt eine ziemlich direkte Linie von
den Geschehnissen in Israel direkt zu
uns nach Deutschland
ähm die Frage der deutschen Straße so
hat Frau sucharewit formuliert Herr
künert war das ein Fehler da soange
tolerant zu sein zu sagen das müssen wir
ertragen das ist Meinungsfreiheit das
gehört nun mal eben dazu nicht so
einfach eine Demonstration zu verbieten
das ist nun mal unser Rechtsstaat das
ist unser Rechtssystem war das ein
Fehler sind ja in Deutschland
verschiedene islamistische
Organisationen verboten bzw auf der EU
Terrorliste mit drauf die Organisation
die wir hier de facto immer im Bild
gesehen haben bei ihren Einspielern eben
samidun ist eine man kann das glaube ich
so sagen eine Tarnorganisation ein
tarnverein ähm der befreiungs einer
befreiungskräfte oder sich als
befreiungskräfte verstehenden ähm Gruppe
aus der palästinensischen Community die
für sich genommen seit 10 Jahren schon
ähm verboten ist und das sind nun die
Wiedergänger man muss allerdings auch
dazu sagen dieser Verein selbst ich hab
mich jetzt im Vorfeld auch noch mal
schlau gemacht hat ganz wenige
Mitglieder als solche und trifft
natürlich auf einen näherboden der
vorhanden ist also diejenigen die dort
die jetzt berühmt gewordenen Süßigkeiten
am Wochenende verteilt haben sind
organisierterweise keine zwei Handvoll
ich hatte gesprochen mit dem Martin
Hiekel den Bezirksbürgermeister von
Berlin Neuköln der noch mal die Zahlen
wiedergegeben hat es gibt allein in
Berlin Neuköln etwa 25 000 Menschen mit
unterschiedlichen arabischen
Hintergründen darunter viele mit
palästinensischen
hintergründ
und diese sehr kleine Gruppe samidun
wirkt als Katalysator für eine Stimmung
die natürlich auch so schon
gesellschaftlich dort ist und die bieten
entsprechende Aktionsformen an ich
glaube wenn es irgendeine rechtliche
Möglichkeit gibt diese Gruppe jetzt auch
zu verbieten sollte man die schnellst
möglich nutzen im Vorfeld der Sendung
bereits gesehen ist zwei angemeldete
Kundgebung für morgen eine in Neuköln
und eine am Pariser Platz bereits von
der Berliner Polizei untersagt worden
sind das sind genau die Zeichen die es
jetzt braucht auch mit exakt dieser
begründ nämlich dass die öffentliche
Ordnung in der Stadt dadurch gefährdet
ist denn genauso ist es auch das ist
dazu geeignet Hass und Gewalt in unsere
Gesellschaft reinzutragen und das dürfen
wir nicht akzeptieren und deswegen finde
ich das gut dass jetzt sehr robust hier
gehandelt wird und glaube das trifft
auch die Erwartung die Frau sucharewit
gerade aus der israelischen Perspektive
gespiegelt hat ich bin mir da nicht
sicher sie gleich noch mal fragen haben
sie auch das Gefühl Lindemann dass wir
da jetzt robust wie K sagt reingen gehen
und konsequent handeln ich glaub dass
dieses Thema seit Jahren unterschätzt
wird ich habe mal Z F paar Monate in
Saudi-Arabien gelebt in Riad während
meiner Promotion und bin wel JR 2005
2005 und seitdem beschäftige ich mich
mit dem politischen Islam mit dem
politischen Islamismus habe viele
Experten in Deutschland von Seiran
attisch Professor kchid Ahmad Mansur
kennengelernt die mir seit Jahren sagen
dieses Thema wird unterschätzt ihr seid
blauäuge
ihr gibt Verbänden Geld ihr gibt
Institution Geld hier in ber in Hamburg
z.B das islamische Zentrum z.te blau
mchee genau seit Jahren reden wir
darüber erstmal
haben genau erstmal die Gelder bekommen
dann wurde das gestoppt jetzt liegt der
verbotserlass seit Monaten bei Frau
Filser auf dem Tisch wird nicht
unterschrieben also es wird weggeschaut
in Deutschland und wir sehen das an in
vielen Bereichen in der clanstruktur wir
sehen es im im Bereich Glitzer Park geht
man nicht mehr rein es der der
muslimische Antisemitismus wird gar
nicht so gesehen sondern nur der
Rechtsradikale und jetzt wird alles
aufgedeckt und meine Sorge ist dass wir
jetzt wieder dre vi F Tage reden und am
Ende passiert nichts und das ist das
Problem glaube ich von Deutschland dass
dieses Problem seit Jahren unterschätzt
wurde dass man jetzt nicht sagt wir
haben es unterschätzt was muss man jetzt
für Konsequenzen ziehen dass diese Leute
Polizisten werfen mit Steinen und
trotzdem hier weiter frei rumlaufen dass
es keine beschleunigte Verfahren gibt
dass Strafen nicht auf dem Fuße folgen
und vieles mehr jedes mal drüber geredet
warum das war ja das ja kein keine
sozusagen nichts was die SPD geführte
Bundesregierung jetzt exklusiv hat
sondern das war ja auch unter der CDU
Kanzlerin Angela Merkel nichts anderes
ich könntest mir jetzt einfach machen
mache ich nicht aber es ist schon so
dass es ein Dissens immer gab zwischen
der CDU und der SPD gerade bei diesem
Thema trotzdem muss man auch sagen ja es
gab dann die Islamkonferenz die hat
damals W schäubler eingeführt was
richtig war dann wurden zum Teil nur
Verbände eingeladen die Experten nicht
mehr es gibt keine Islamverbände
eigentlich in Deutschland weil die nicht
so organisiert wir sind wie der wie die
katholischen und die evangelischen
sondern da gibt es ein Verband
ähm Zentralrat der Muslime ich glaube
1,2% Muslime vertreten die mhm haben das
relativiert alles so heute ein bisschen
schärfer formuliert aber so richtig klar
auch nicht genau und da erwarte ich
meine heute war Ron prosor bei uns in
der Fraktion das war für mich historisch
diese Sitzung werde ich nie vergessen
heute Nachmittag der israelische
Botschafter ein Hoch integrer kluger
Kopf der genau das gemacht hat Masala
Herr malala der gesagt hat ich erwarte
jetzt von euch Solidarität dass das was
in den nächsten Tagen passiert und das
wird hart ich habe eben im Zug den
Fehler gemacht mir so ein Video auch mal
anzuschauen mache ich nie wieder weil
das macht ja was mit unserem Gehirn wir
versuchen natürlich unschuldig nicht zu
treffen aber natürlich wird es passieren
und wir müssen so hart zurückschlagen
dass niemand auch nur im Ansatz auf den
Gedanken kommt nochmals Israel
anzugreifen und das wird hart und diese
Solidarität erwarte ich von ihnen wir
sind wir haben geklatscht wir haben
Respekt gezollt und ich habe wirklich
Gänsehaut bekommen und dann hatte ich
noch eine Situation wenn ich das auch
sagen darf dann kam er schäupler auf
mich zu und sagt der LN müssen alles tun
für das Thema innere Sicherheit ich war
zweimal Innenminister wir müssen die
Nachrichtendienste ist nicht meine
Aufgabe Frau Feser und andere klar
anweisen jetzt hohe Sicherheitsstufe
weil natürlich die Sicherheitslage hier
sind natürlich auch Schläfer in
Deutschland Islamisten in Deutschland
die beobachtet werden und vieles mehr wo
natürlich jetzt das kommen kann was sie
sagen Herr Massala nämlich an
Flächenbrand und das darf nicht
passieren und da müssen wir jetzt hoch
konzentriert und bitte nicht
parteipolitisch agieren sondern wirklich
es jetzt auch so ändern dass
Konsequenzen gezogen werden sieht das
Kevin günert auch so das ist jetzt schon
mal eben nicht so gut gelungen mit dem
nicht pararteipolitisch aufnutzen ich
will es jetzt nicht mit selber Münze
zurückzahlen weil das gehört sich bei
dem Thema nicht aber ich glaube
Unterstellung dass irgendjemand das
nicht ernst nehmen würde oder indirekt
dass es quasi jetzt zu dieser Situation
gekommen wäre weil irgendjemand gepennt
hätte oder so gesag islamische Zentrum
hambur verfassungchut haben Gelder
bekommen und ist bis heute nicht
verboten worden ja islamische Zentrum in
Hamburg da haben wir hier auch schon in
der Sendung mal drüber gesprochen sollte
ich denke wird auch in absehbarer Zeit
geschlossen W sind es geht über Jahre
Jahre ja aber wir müssen jetzt ein
bisschen aufpassen dass wir gerade nicht
alles zusammenwerfen was wir so im
Repertoire mit drin haben wenn wir jetzt
mit girler Park und allem ankommen es
war jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen viel
Mixtur an dieser Stelle wir haben ein
Problem mit Antisemitismus erstmal ja in
Deutschland an verschiedenen Stellen
also jüdische Menschen wissen
Antisemitismus hat viele sichichter
jetzt reden wir gerade aktuell und zwar
völlig berechtigt mal wieder über
islamisch oder islamistisch motivierten
Antisemitismus kürzlich ist die
mittstudie Friedrich Ebert Stiftung
wieder rausgekommen die leider zeigt
dass jeder Fünfte in Deutschland
antisemitische und unterschiedlich stark
ausgeprägte Grundeinstellungen hat wir
haben mit Attentaten wie in Halle und
anders wo gesehen das Antisemitismus von
ganz vielen Seiten droht so das ist
jetzt kein Ablenkungsmanöver heute haben
wir über dieses Thema zu sprechen und
wir werden noch lange darüber zu
sprechen haben aber wir dürfen es uns
jetzt glaube ich nicht so einfach machen
der entscheidende Punkt ist vorhin in
den Eingangsstatements gesagt worden das
Wichtigste was wir jetzt und auf
absehbare Zeit leisten können ist solid
echte Solidarität und Geschlossenheit
auch quer durch die demokratischen
Parteien hindurch unsere
Parteivorsitzenden haben am Wochenende
nicht nur die von unseren Parteien ähm
haben einen guten Anfang gemacht wir
werden diese Woche eine
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
mit einer gemeinsamen Resolution im
Deutschen
Bundestag dementsprechend haben wir
waren ich mit mein Parteivorsitzenden
sie mit dem
Parteivorsitzenden auf dem Pariser Platz
das ist alles richtig und notwendig der
entscheidende Punkt wird sie haben es
alle angesprochen in den nächsten Wochen
kommen wenn die Bilder zunehmend aus
Gaza kommen dann muss die Solidarität
immer noch stehen man muss das den
Menschen in Deutschland auch ganz
deutlich was heißt das was heißt das ja
man muss das ganz deutlich sagen dieser
warum haben wir diese besondere
Beziehung zu Israel ja nicht nur aus
unserer Geschichte heraus man muss das
ja wirklich noch mal noch mal Darleen
Deutschland trägt Verantwortung für das
was jüdischen Menschen auf der ganzen
Welt im Rahmen der scha angetan wurde
für den industriellen Massenmord an
Jüden und Juden der Staat Israel ist
heute auf dieser Welt der einzige
Schutzraum für jüdisches genau Leben es
geht einem kaum über die Lippen wenn man
die Bilder dieser Tage sieht denn dieser
Schutzraum wird jetzt ganz konkret
angegriffen das heißt es gibt für
jüdisches Leben im Moment bei solchen
Bildern wie sie gerade Abkommen keinen
funktionierenden Schutzraum deswegen
wehrt dieser Staat sich und wenn dieses
Land Deutschland sein Versprechen ernst
meint und aufrechterhalten will dass wir
nie wieder nie wieder zulassen dass
jüdisches Leben in dieser Welt
ausgelöscht wird dann gilt das nicht nur
für unser Territorium sondern auch für
den Ort wo die meisten jüdischen
Menschen weltweit sich nun eben
niedergelassen und ihren Staat aufgebaut
haben das ist Israel man muss sich auf
der Zunge zergehen lassen die Anzahl an
Menschen wir wissen noch nicht wie viele
es sind aber mindestens ein h die Anzahl
an jüdischen Menschen die dort am
vergangenen Samstag ermordet worden sind
von der Hamas das ist die größte Anzahl
seit ermordeter Juden seit
1945 seit Ende der Schoa über diese
Dimension sprechen wir und da ist es
nicht angebracht jetzt sind irgendwelche
ja aber Diskussionen und mir schmeckt
aber die israelische Regierung nicht
oder ähnliches zu verfallen denn das hat
nichts miteinander zu tun dieser Staat
wird in Gänze angegriffen hier wird
nicht Herr Netanyahu oder ein Mitglied
seines Kabinetts angegriffen es wird
jüdisches Leben angegriffen es ist auch
nicht der Regierungspalast es ging
natürlich auch nicht angegriffen worden
sondern es sind kibozime ja also da
haben junge Menschen alternative
lebenskulturen ausgelebt ein Festival
gelebt wer also behauptet das sei
irgendwie Widerstand gegen eine
Besatzung oder ähnliches Bullshit es ist
so ziemlich der dämlichste Ort den man
hätte wählen können wenn man die
Administration in Israel hätte treffen
wollen all diese ablenkungsm verbieten
sich und dem muss robust auch in der
deutschen Öffentlichkeit wiedersprochen
W dar ich ganz kurz was hinzufügen bei
dieser ganzen romantisier danke Kevin K
für diese klaren Worte bei dieser ganzen
Romantisierung die man findet des
sogenannten palästinensischen
Widerstandes die Hamas ist eine
Organisation die seit Beginn sich die
Vernichtung Israels auf ihre fahen
geschrieben hat das ist keine Bewegung
sozusagen die sich irgendwann mal
radikalisiert hat weil die Situation so
schlimm ist sondern die ist explizit
gegründet worden mit dem Ziel der
Vernichtung Israel 87 ne und von daher
sozusagen kann es kein ja aber geben
weil es das Ziel dieser Gruppierung ist
sie setzen das um was sie sozusagen
wofür sie gegründet wurden und sind
damit überhaupt sozusagen kein
Repräsentant für irgendeine
palästinensische Sache und das ist was
halt das ist ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt
wenn ich kurz einhaken kann hier
äh apropos ja aber dass dieses Jahr aber
tabu werden muss ich glaub darum darüber
sind wir uns zumindest in dieser Runde
einig und und das wird sehr geschätzt
das heißt Haltung zeigen Format zeigen
aber die Hamas hat im Endeffekt
über viele viele Jahre hinweg
äh durch seine
propagandaschinerie es geschafft die
gazablockade auch in Deutschland zu
einem großen großen tragischen in ein
großes großes tragisches
missglück der palästinensischen
Gesellschaft gewandelt und im Endeffekt
ist das einzigste was die Palästinenser
zwischen Freiheit äh und äh und diesem
Gefängnis trennt diese israelische
Blockade die genau
dafür erlegt wurde um dafür zu sorgen um
zu verhindern dass Waffen geschmuggelt
werden dass Tunnels gebaut werden dass
die Gelder die aus der EU und aus
anderen
Quellen dorthin fließen für Tunnels
benutzt werden anstatt für Schulen für
raketenarsenale für für raketenfabriken
anstatt für Krankenhäuser genau das war
der Grund warum diese Blokade auferlegt
wurde und es gibt es verging keine
Operation kein Krieg kein Angriff gegen
Israel der nicht irgendwie doch auch in
der öffentlichen Meinung auch in
Deutschland legitimiert wurde na ja aber
die sind halt von den Israelis in dieses
Gefängnis gesckt wie sollen sie sich
denn sonst whren auch da das äh muss in
dem neuen Paradigma nach dem 7 7 Oktober
das muss vorbei sein Eva Quadbeck hat
gerade genickt als sie sagten dieses jah
aber das muss ein Ende haben sehen sie
auch
so absolut also das kann nicht sein dass
man jetzt sagt okay die Israelis haben
ja auch Fehler gemacht und in
irgendeiner Form versucht zu
relativieren was eben am 7 Oktober
passiert ist was ich aber auch warum ich
auch genickt habe es ist eben nicht
damit getan wenn jetzt der Verein
samidou verboten wird der ja
nachweislich die Verbindung hat zu
dieser palästinensischen Volksfront wie
sie sich nennen die übrigens nicht nur
islamistisch ist die überhaupt nicht
islamistisch ist sondern die säkular ist
und die marxistisch lenistische
Verbindungen hat und
das ist das was er eben auch
angesprochen worden ist das ist eben
sehr breit in die Gesellschaft
eingeträufelt worden man hat eben diesen
wie wir ja eben auch beschrieben haben
diesen
vernichtungsantisemitismus gegen Israel
der ist eben kommt nicht nur von der
islamistischen Seite sondern er kommt
auch aus einer ja verbrämten politisch
linksextremen Seite die mit dafür
gesorgt hat dass eben diese Extremisten
seit Jahren auf die Straße gehen können
obwohl wir eigentlich uns alle einig
sind dass wir solche Bilder in
Deutschland nicht ertragen wollen
weil sie sich gegen den Staat Israel
gegen die Juden wenden und weil sie eben
auch immer Gewaltaufrufe beinhaltet
haben und
ich sehe noch einen zweiten Punkt das
hat der Lindemann gerade angesprochen es
ist sicherlich so dass auch in
Deutschland die Sicherheitslage sich
verändert dass man noch jetzt mehr
darauf achten muss dass es zu
islamistischen
Anschlägen kommen kann infolge eben
einer Solidarisierung einer radikalen
Solidarisierung der Islamisten mit den
Palästinensern und das ist eben dann
auch noch mal eine zweite Sache nebendem
dass man natürlich unverbrüchlich diese
Solidarität zu Israel jetzt
aufrechterhalten muss mit allen
politischen Konsequenzen haben wir zudem
auch noch ein Sicherheitsproblem ein
zusätzliches und das ist das was ich
meine wenn ich sage es reicht nicht
diesen Verein zu verbieten sondern man
wird auch gegen andere islamistische
näer
härter vorgehen müssen einmal um dieses
Versprechen der Staatsraison einzulösen
aber auch um die eigene Bevölkerung und
auch um die jüdinen und Juden in
Deutschland zu schützen